You didn't even know.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
[Silence]
in the chapter of patience of
offered by authored by Will we
the 25th narration the first narration
of the chapter 25th of the book
he mentions the narration of Malik
Ali well-known narration.
It's an narration that has many
subjects and it's considered
fundamental
in each chapter and in each subject that
it touches upon.
He the prophet sallall.aii Wasallam
says in the final two sentences of the
narration
and the Quran
is either an argument for you or against
you.
Here we have a method of speaking in
which the prophet sallall.aii Wasallam
uses
the word
or the pronoun you
without intending necessarily
the
listener, the one who is being spoken
to. He says you, not necessarily the one
that he's speaking to particularly,
but the hypothetical
and also the that this rule applies
to every person who is fit to be hearing
these words.
Now in this statement he tells us that
the Quran is
an argument for you or against you.
This is not specific to Abu Mus.
This is general to any person. Every
human being who fits the criteria to be
held accountable for his actions.
Every human being
who fits the criteria
of being accountable for his or her
actions.
What is that criteria?
that a person be
of age, the age of puberty, pub age,
and that the person be sane,
meaning that they are able to hold a
coherent intention
and that this person
has heard of the Quran.
But the narration could actually be even
more general than that. When we say has
heard of the Quran, Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala tells the prophet Sam
in
that this Quran has been sent to me,
sent down upon me
in order that I can
warn you all with it and anyone whom
whom this Quran reaches in one of the
explanations of this verse. Anyone whom
this Quran reaches,
do they have to have heard of all of the
Quran, every verse, in order for it to
be a an argument for them or against
them? No, of course not.
Anyone who has heard of the prophet
Muhammad sallall.aii alaihi wasallam has
heard of Islam, has heard of the Quran,
then this person also has a
responsibility
to investigate why it is he or she
exists. Often times
we start to kind of
start to imagine that the people are
owed general people the general masses
of humanity are owed to be spoonfed
every little thing. This is not correct.
human beings. Every single human being
who fits this criteria has a
responsibility
to ask the question, why do I exist? And
a responsibility
to do his or her best to come to a
conclusion and find an answer to that
question.
It is not sufficient for a person to
say, well, you know, I'm just going on
through my life and I don't know, it's
unclear why we're here or who created
us, but I'm too busy to really, you
know, look into that and who am I
anyways? I'm not a philosopher or a
scholar or anything that. So live
and let live, you know, I just do my
best and right that's not enough. It's
not especially for a creature that has
been given such intelligence
and
endowed with free will and endowed with
so many faculties by which to
investigate
to ask the right questions and to
come to conclusions to these
questions. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
said
He says, "Subhan,
have we not given the human being two
eyes,
two lips and a tongue and guided him to
the concept of the two paths?" What is
the concept of the two paths? This is
speaking about the fra
the fra that a person has in his heart.
The two paths the path of right and the
path of wrong.
This is right and this is wrong. This is
this is respectable. This is
this is not
this is correct. This is incorrect. This
is honorable. This is dishonorable.
Every human being a person has this
innately in himself. They have an
intrinsic
sense of good and bad. It might be very
very you know broad. It's not it's
not detailed.
That's what the Quran and Sunnah are
for. But it is a broad broad strokes of
intrinsic
morality,
right and wrong.
Every human being immediately as soon as
they are born, as long as they are sane,
as long as they can understand, little
little children, as soon as they can
speak or even before they're even able
to form words,
before they're even able to express
in intelligent speech, they
have a physiological
response to lying and deception and
treachery,
a physiological response.
When they when a little baby tells a
lie, immediately heart rate goes up.
They know it's wrong. This is wrong.
This is not right. Where does this come
from?
[Silence]
And so this is the that Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala has created the human being
upon.
When a person is going through his life,
no matter how wealthy he is or how poor
he is, how busy he is or how much free
time he has,
they hear about Muhammad sallall.aii
wasallam. They see especially in this
time day and age that
onethird of the earth's population
follows this man and recites this book
has access to the Quran
at every turn. If if you were to try to
go through your life anywhere on earth
that is a civilized society
and make it your business to avoid
coming into contact with the Quran, you
would be hardressed to do so. It's
everywhere.
And then the person decides this isn't
worth my time. Right? That's a decision
that a person makes that will be held to
account for that decision. A person has
a responsibility to investigate and to
ask questions.
And often times we imagine
that
when a person,
you know, they're too busy or whatever
it is to investigate
and to ask questions about who the
prophet sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam
was or what the Quran is or what the
Muslims are, what Islam is that, you
know, it just never occurred to them.
That's not true.
Every single person in this room right
now, every person that you've ever met
has had instances in his life where he
is either on the brink of death, thinks
they're going to die in a situation
where they are fearing for their life.
And at that moment they promised to be
better
and they promised to seek answers.
Every single person here and every
person you've ever met
has made that agreement with Allah
when hard times come.
However,
the human being
by nature is usually a treacherous
creature by nature.
Few people will fulfill and follow
through with such a promise with such a
vow.
So the point here is that the pro the
prophet sallall.aii Wasam tells us here
that
once a person has heard of the Quran,
once a person has been given
broad
honest representation of the Quran,
albeit small, albeit brief,
it is not so incredibly distorted
the image they're given of Islam so
incredibly ly distorted so as anyone in
his right mind would reject it
then this person has a relationship with
the Quran. Now it is either an argument
for you or against you and this is one
more point that we will take from the
narration before we end and that is
the issue of
comparison.
We often compare ourselves to other
people either to make ourselves feel
better or to excuse our behavior that we
know is inexcusable.
So we will say for instance to
ourselves, well you know I'm not as bad
as this person over here. I'm not as bad
as that person. at least I'm better than
this person seemingly or
a person justifies his foul actions
because of the actions of another say
well this person was bad to me so I'm
bad to them this person abused me so I
abuse others etc
no one is going to be judged based on
other people
We will be judged based on the Quran.
On the day of judgment, every one of us
will be compared
to the standards of the Quran. What we
knew of it, what we could have known of
it,
and what we did with that knowledge.
This is what we will be compared to. we
won't be compared to the lowest amongst
us or the weakest in faith amongst us.
And so the scholars of Islam, they tell
us when a person seeks to compare
himself in the dunya,
he compares himself
to the most unfortunate.
So he can always be grateful.
But when he wishes to compare himself
in issues of of religion and dean, he
compares himself to the best. He doesn't
say
I wish I had more so and so has
more. That's not it.
Rather they say alhamdulillah I have
more than so and so. And in the they say
I should be
so and so of the companions of the
of the scholars of Islam of the best of
people.
One should not compare himself to the
weakest in faith and say well I'm at
least better than that.
forham.
[Silence]
I